foreign
ER deafening volleys of gunfire as
people run for their lives
a brief lull allows locals to help
someone injured and carry him to safety
then more gunfire
a military vehicle in flames in the
background
earlier chanting demonstrators
frustrated by Rising prices power
outages and water Cuts stormed the
governor's office and set it on fire
the building was empty at the time
[Music]
they're calling for the removal of
President Bashar al-assad a poster of
him displayed outside the building was
torn down and ripped to pieces
many voiced their frustrations
and poverty have killed us there are
those whom we respect and honor among
our great people who are not satisfied
with what is happening now
the town has largely escaped serious
11-year Civil War
but its citizens haven't been afraid to
take to the streets anti-government
protests took place in 2020 and again in
February this year State media reports
condemned the actions of what they call
Outlaws but with inflation above 130
percent the anger seems unlikely to
subside anytime soon Nick talks Big Al
Jazeera